はい。というわけで本日3月31日。YouTubeのほうでチャンネル登録者数を見てみますと、なんと300万人を突破しました。
ありがとうございますッ！
多分なんですけど、日本初です。
日本初、チャンネル登録者300万人超えということで、
今日はですね、まずは、
本当にチャンネル登録してくださった皆様
そして！いつも僕のマジでしょーもない動画を見てくださっている皆様、
本当にかっ・・・ありがとうございます。
ここまでこれたのは本当に皆様のおかげです。
まぁこれからもわけのわからない動画もあると思います。
去年末にもありましたニベア風呂みたいな
たまにハメを外すこともあると思いますが
これからもよろしくお願いします
で　あの僕最近思ったんですけど
最近すごい「おめでとう」って言われることがめちゃくちゃ多い
めっちゃ多いんですよ
誕生日から始まってからな
誕生日2月14日誕生日誕生日おめでとう
ありがとうございます
単位取れました。卒業確定おめでとう
チャンネル登録者数が日本一になりました。おめでとう
ありがとうございます！
卒業式　ついに卒業か　卒業おめでとう
そして　チャンネル登録者300万人おめでとうございます
ありがとうございます！
もう何か・・・死にます。
近々死にます。ってくらいちょっとびびってる
何なんだろうね。すごい今ピークが来てます。
そういういいこと続いた後は多分落ちると思うんで
いつでも落ちてもいいぐらいの気持ちでちょっと
これからもがんばらさせていただきます。
でね！
何かスゲーいいことばっかりじゃんはじめみたいに思っている人もいると思うんですけども
そうじゃないっすよ
いいことばっかりあると思ったら大間違いだ
僕がいつも使っているこのカメラ
EOS70Dが昨日
ありがとうございます！
マジできつい
今これ充電してたMAXの充電ですね
入れます。電源つけます。
ギャーー
ちょっと1年半ぐらい使ったEOS70Dが完全にぶっ壊れました
消耗品だから　壊れることもあると思うんですけど
同じく同日
SONY用のカメラのレンズがぶっ壊れました
分かるかな　微妙に浮いてるんですよ
でこれもどうしようもなくて何か
こうカメラにつけたら何かウクシウクシウクシウクシウクシ
ピピピピピピピピピ　バーン
うぁーー
そうなんすよ　いいことばっかりじゃないんですよ
同じ日に二つも物が壊れる　レンズとカメラ
300万人ってうれしいんですけど
ずっと使ってたカメラが壊れたりして何か複雑な心境です。はじめしゃちょーです。
4月入る前に300万人ぴっちり行けたんでほんとによかったです。
やりたいことたくさんあるんですけど
それをやって、僕はすごく面白いと思うんですけども
見ている子供たちとか　こう　なんか　それを真似して危なかったりすると危ないので
見る人が多いってなるとやっぱ自分の好きなことをバンバンやってるだけでもダメだなって思ってきて
やっぱそういうとこは気をつけていかなきゃなと思っております
まぁそれでもハメを外す時は
外すけどな
ハメは外すんですけども
今までどおり好きなことをただやってるだけだとやっぱダメなんで
まぁなかなかね
周りに気をつかいながら頑張っていきます
あ～でもな過激なことして～な～
過激なことしてぇ！
そういう事も考慮しながら今後頑張っていきます
でなんかねーちょっと最近ねー
言いたいことがあったんですよ
小学生の夢
将来の夢
日本の将来を危惧する人多数
まじか～
で　いろんなひとの意見を見るとですね～
やばくねみたいな人が多いですね